lors de leur beau non c'est vrai mais
rageux l'adorent vraiment awel loi est
super sympa gentil et tout mais vous
êtes sûr que vous confondez pas c'est
pas de préférer matthieu delormeau ah
ouais moi c'est vrai ah oui ah ouais et
les autres noms noms là d'accord je vous
fais sur arthur c'est bon d'avoir le roi
ou moi merde si tu pars dans les deux
pieds klein dos et sur quelqu un m a bon
dos et isabelle dépeint dossier soit un
tout petit truc sur jean-michel si j'ose
dire allez-y c'est quoi heynckes vous me
regardez le mois non ma mère la baronne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aussi de dire des conneries pareilles
non je suis comme ça je crois qu'on a un
bec en fait de croiser le regard d'un
dos mais la balle je suis myope de
neuilly permettra de l'eau donc des fois
j'ai dû m'ajuster à thé permettra
d'atteindre une meilleure était à m tu
vois que prisa verdier je veux dire il
permettra de dire ah ouais bah ils
voient pas et voient pas de prêt il
permettra pensée presse buisson c'est
progresse bien mais aussi possible
d'accord merci alors oui oui ménagers a
annoncé me jean louis le ya quinze jours
en loge alors qu'on les aime tous mort
vaut pas sûrement un bisou de la 15
jours en loge alors que personne ne lui
demande d strictement rien vous avez
volé les pattes d'un caniche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui alors donc avant qu'on lui demande d
strictement rien jean-michel à baisser
culotte elle nous a montré son recto
verso plutôt son rectum verso non mais
c'est place et j'ai tout fait mais je
vous garantis que quinze jours seraient
ensuite toujours pas remise
il ya une sorte de fil rouge quand même
souvenir faut pas le faire heureusement
que j'étais pas là sa vie dans la loge
oui jolie jours et s'est dit